elle est passée de l'ombre à la lumière
en quelques semaines à peine une
notoriété due à une simple pétition en
ligne pour une baisse des prix des
carburants à la pompe
lancée le 29 mai dernier cette requête
publique a recueilli plus de huit cent
dix mille signatures en un peu plus de
cinq mois dans son appartement de la
banlieue sud de paris
celle qui est en partie à l'origine du
mouvement des gilets jaunes garde la
tête sur les épaules
le positionne plutôt comme un porte
parole sam est une forme de pression
dans le sang son moi j'espère
retranscrire correctement et pensées des
uns et des autres et voilà je suis
contente aussi de recevoir les
témoignages les retours de personnes sur
des interventions que je fais et ça ne
rassemble conforte dans le fait sur le
fait par don que je suis sur la bonne
ligne est née il ya 33 ans en région
parisienne de parents martinique et de
trinité et du gros morne devenu en
hexagone dans les années 80 pour
travailler cette célibataire surplomb le
grand public quand les gens découvrent
son visage alors qu'elle porte un nom
d'origine polonaise
non je pense que j'en attendais pas on
m'attendait pas moins de toute façon et
après qui plaisait oui une femme une
femme d'origine antillaise
oui certainement encore moi j'imagine
ancienne spécialiste en finances
internationales dans une grande banque
française cette seine et marnaise vont
désormais des produits cosmétiques bio
sur internet et travaille à lancer sa
propre ligne de cosmétiques naturels
priscilla utilise beaucoup sa voiture
pour ses déplacements professionnels 45
euros d'essence par semaine l'an passé
près du double aujourd'hui alors qu'elle
a réduit ses déplacements sur la route
un vrai manque à gagner pour cet
automobiliste qui ne peut travailler
sans son véhicule on a la chance de
pouvoir alterner les transports en
commun mais qui ne fonctionne pas très
bien au quotidien ya beaucoup de
personnes qui peuvent en témoigner tous
les jours et effectivement en zone
rurale ou même dans des dans des villes
dans les grandes villes où les
transports en commun sont pas très
efficacement plus ou alors en partie
néant partis existants ça leur pose
problème à ces personnes là puisqu'elles
ont besoin du véhicule quotidiennement
et oui c'est les personnes qui elles
vivent de plein fouet l'augmentation des
taxes hors carburant 2
l'une des figures du mouvement national
des gilets jaunes pris si bienne avait
jusqu alors jamais milité dans aucun
parti ni mouvement ni association
cette pétition sur internet et sa
première expérience militante qui au
regard du succès rencontré risque de
l'entraîner vers d'autres aventures de
la sorte toujours été un petit peu
sensible aux injustices et le vois bien
continuer à défendre certaines causes
qui avait effectivement tiennent à coeur
à favars les moyens et le temps en fait
surtout je pense que si j'avais eu le
temps pas auparavant j'aurais peut-être
déjà commencé plus tôt en attendant ces
futurs engagements restent à cette jeune
antillaise a passé son baptême du feu le
17 novembre prochain avec l'appel
national au blocage des routes par le
collectif des gilet jaune